okay good morning everyone welcome to
the NCBI minute this is the first one of
these we've done as a webinar my name is
Peter Cooper and with me this morning is
Tao who's Manning the questions pod the
idea behind these NCBI minutes is that
they should be very brief webinars that
are basically designed to introduce you
to an NCBI resource that you might not
be familiar with or to give you a tip
about using one that you already aren't
familiar with but you know there's some
trick that we don't think you know about
that might make your life easier the
sort of business things are up here on
the slide we will make a video recording
of this and all of our webinars I just
wanted to remind everybody that we do
have a YouTube channel and the address
of our YouTube channel is there with a
link to the playlist section and so
we'll have a webinars playlist and some
of these webinars may be crossed posted
with other playlists that we have for
example class since this is a short
webinar I'm not going to have time to
really address questions orally during
the webinar so put in the question spot
Cal will answer ones that are quick he
types fast ones that are taking a little
longer to respond to or ones where we
have to look for the answers we'll get
back to you on that we'll put those
things up and they'll link them to the
webinars page and the URL for our new
version of our webinars pages there at
the bottom of this slide this is a link
to our learn button that's on the front
of our homepage now okay so this morning
we're going to talk about a utility
called mole-blast mole-blast is a way of
clustering sequences and finding their
nearest neighbors in the NCBI sequence
database it then makes a phylogenetic
tree of those sequences and what it's
good for is for working with what I'm
going to call targeted sequences we
often call these things targeted to
low-side these are things like ribosomal
RNA genes from bacteria or fungi or even
things like a cytochrome oxidase one it
uses blast to initial do the initial
clustering and generates a multiple
alignment using muscle ximena
phylogenetic tree people who use this
could be people like texana --mess
people who are interested in
evolutionary biology people who are
doing ecological studies with medici
nose
and of course we use it here to confirm
identifications and to see a thing like
something might be misidentified
certainly people that submit the NCBI
can use this a tool to identify their
own sequences that confirmed it they're
what they think they are the materials
and sort of the examples that I'm going
to use our link to the FTP site and
they're in there and I'm going to go
ahead and go now to the blast homepage
and then link them all s so let me go
ahead and do that here well I'm actually
I think what I'm going to do is escape
from my slide set and we'll just go
there directly so let me go ahead and do
that and so what I'm going to do is go
over here and go to the this is the NCBI
home page of course and if you go to our
blast page if you scroll down mole-blast
is linked down here in our specialized
blast section of the page and I'm going
to go ahead and follow the link to maul
blast so in low blast lets you submit a
list of nucleotide accessions or fast a
formatted sequences and it gives you
some guidelines as to how big those can
be so we're going to go ahead and pick a
set from the NCBI databases and do that
real quick so the one that I'm going to
use over here that I have already loaded
in one of my tabs and this is available
on the FTP site this is a set of clones
that were identified are 16s ribosomal
RNA genes that were sequenced from one
of our pop sets this is from a
wastewater on meta-genome and so when
you can quickly do on an entree page
like this is go ahead and set the
display to accession list hit apply and
then I have a set a set of 50 accessions
that I could quickly just grab copy them
and throw them into mole-blast
so I'm going to paste those in there and
I can run this let me just go over a
couple of settings here and we'll
probably have time to do just the one
example this morning so I just want to
show you how this works I could search
against the default in our database and
that's going to be useful if I'm using
one of the non targeted sequences or one
that we don't have a separate database
for notice that I can pick right now the
16s ribosomal RNA sequences that we have
as a reference collection and those are
the ones that I would want to use to try
to identify these
unknown organisms or partially
identified organisms that are in this
set so I can pick that as my database
and then notice like on the regular
blast page there are some advanced
parameters here I can choose my search
program I'm going to use mega blasted
faster it fix a set of sequences for me
it can also exclude things if I'm going
to research against the in our database
it might be useful to exclude uncultured
sample sequences because they won't give
me much in the way of confirming my
identification also notice that I can
check this sequences from tight material
box which is very useful when we search
our 60s or either so molarity database
what you're going to find is that many
of those are going to be from site
material and that gave you some
confirmation about the identity of the
organism involved mobile apps will
cluster see query sequences by low side
with those low side often are going to
be different genes if you have a mixed
set in many cases the cluster is going
to be governed by how good your
sequences are how long they are with the
quality of the alignments are as well so
we can adjust those parameters and for
example this example that I'm going to
do right now you could go back and you
can play around with this and see if you
can change the number of clusters by
changing the percent identity so one
thing that's very helpful to do with
megablast because we don't have an edit
and resubmit with mole-blast excuse me
if the hint that shows the sequence
results a new window and you run it I'm
gonna go ahead and just submit that but
because mole-blast takes a couple of
minutes to run I'm just going to go
ahead and get the results because I have
them stored so I'm gonna go back here to
my submission page and get the recent
results tab here so notice that
mole-blast stores are id's exactly the
same way that blas does and so I'm just
gonna retrieve one I've got them saved
here in a little text pad so I can
remember what they are
I'm just going to copy that one and
retrieve my results and so the default
display is to show you a tree that's
based on that multiple alignment and so
this would be very useful if I was
interested in knowing for example the
kinds of taxonomic units that were in my
environmental sample and I can see on
the right hand side they're color-coded
here by major groups of bacteria these
are the classes of bacteria from this
page I can also get to the tree itself
and download it and some formats that I
can work with locally I can also see an
alignment so if I click here I can get
to the mussel based multiple sequence
alignment so there it is a large number
of sequences we have 50 plus the
database sequences that I asked for how
many of these are these these NR
sequences here are going to be our
reference collection of 16s ribosomal
RNA sequences I noticed from this page I
can also edit resubmit this to run
muscle again if I decide that there are
some sequences that I don't want to
include I can remove them and realign
the whole thing
by going up here to the top and just
realign them let me go back to the tree
view here and if you're familiar with
their tree view all the same
functionality exists here that exists on
the blast pages I can display smaller
sections of the tree and I can splay
smaller sections of the multiple
sequence alignment so I think that's all
we really have time for today I just
wanted to make sure that everybody knew
about mole-blast
and how to get to it and what you can do
with it there are some additional
examples that are available on that file
on the FTP site and so that was that's a
conclusion basically of one of these
NCBI minutes there Tim intend to be
fairly short and we'll have another one
next week on the 15th like I said we
don't have time to answer questions
early but if you put them in the
questions pod we will try to get them
and get them up on a document on the
webinars page ok well thank you very
much for coming to the first NCBI minute
and make sure that you check out our
YouTube channel and subscribe to that so
you can see whenever we put new videos
up there that I couldn't just be the
webinar videos there will also be
individual recordings of how to do
things and other types of things like
that